nintendo is opening up about new console
concerns and bioware is reacting to mass
effect 5 rumors
during a japanese investor q a this week
nintendo president shantaro furukawa
spoke about how the company plans to
transition away from the switch console
in the future translated by vgc furukawa
said quote unlike the past we continue
to have a large variety of games
scheduled to be released even beyond 5
years of release this is because the
nintendo switch has had such a smooth
launch allowing us to focus all of our
development resources on a single
platform however the question of whether
we will be able to just as smoothly
transition from the nintendo switch to
the next generation of hardware is a
major concern for us in order to ensure
it doesn't lose its massive user base
shantaro explained that nintendo's
strategy is to provide services that
also use nintendo accounts and other ip
outside of gaming software and while
we're on the subject of switch and
switch games mario rabbids sparks of
hope which was initially announced for
2022 has a new release window as a part
of ubisoft's latest earnings briefing
the company confirmed that it has more
games in development right now than ever
before in its history and this includes
a handful of big name games coming out
in the next year for fiscal year 2020
through 23 aka april 1st 2022 through
march 31st 2023 ubisoft will release a
handful of high profile games including
avatar frontiers of pandora mario plus
rabbits sparks of hope and skull and
bones i'm still convinced skull bones is
never coming out but i'd love to be
proven wrong
ubisoft didn't announce specific release
dates for any of these projects but the
avatar game launching around the time
that the new movie launches in december
would make sense but you know what
doesn't make sense
how i've never been interested in smite
yet here i am determined to fall in love
with the game just so i can play as
slipknot members comment what game you
started playing just because of a
collaboration i'm pretty sure a common
thread in the answers are gonna be
fortnite and then the runner up is gonna
be warzone but all right let's switch
gears a bit and talk about mass effect
bioware has responded to internet
speculation that commander shepard will
return in the next mass effect game and
it sounds like that's not gonna be the
case a poster version of the teaser art
for the next mass effect game featured
on the bioware gear store contained a
description that read quote shepard's
final quest may have ended the threat of
the reapers but at great cost including
earth itself while shepard and the
survivors are left to pick up the pieces
fans are left wondering what's next the
description kicked off discussion online
that the next mass effect game could
bring back shepard the text has since
been updated to remove shepard's name
however and bioware's mike gamble issued
a statement on twitter that said quote
yeah that was a mistake fixed in another
tweet gamble said quote the original
thing was written by the people who run
the store and aren't familiar with the
game neither of gamble's statements
however mentions shepard by name or
confirm that the character will not
return in the next mass effect game only
that the text of the production
description was a mistake and if you're
curious what we want from the next mass
effect you can check out this video
where lucy discusses what the next entry
in the franchise can take from the
trilogy as well as andromeda on a scale
of 1 to 10 how badly do you want shepard
to return and also on a scale of 1 to 10
how confident are you in me becoming a
smite pro
because i'm telling you i'm going to get
into it i mean
the characters are are coming out and
i'm i'm going to start playing it i'm
going to start learning it i'm going to
change my middle name to moba all right
maybe not that part
i'll see you tomorrow
you